[Music]
this uranium one story has been debunked
countless times it is nothing but a you
know a false charge that the Trump
administration is trying to drum up in
order to avoid attention being directed
at them this is such an abuse of power
and it goes right at the rule of law if
they send a signal that we're gonna be
like some dictatorship some
authoritarian regime where political
opponents are going to be unfairly
fraudulently investigated that rips at
the fabric of the contract we have that
we can trust our justice system really
hell are you talking about the rule of
law and the possibility of a special
counsel to investigate her role and that
whole corrupt uranium one deal she's
obviously getting nervous he was more
reaction author of the best-selling book
Clinton cash really we're gonna get a
lecture on the rule of law you know I I
watch people now assail you even the
never Trump crowd is now trying to come
to the defense I noticed of Hillary
Clinton I want to give you a chance to
respond and explain to people all of the
connections here I'll hand it to you
well thanks Sean look this is a story
that begins in 2005 a Bill Clinton and
Hillary Clinton helped Frank Giustra
Canadian investor get very very rich
uranium deposits in Kazakhstan from the
Kazakh government and we now have a
video deposition from the Kazakh uranium
minister at the time going into detail
about how they were extorted by
then-senator Hillary Clinton to grant
those concessions to Frank Giustra she
was on the Armed Services Committee she
would not meet with Kazakh officials her
committee had responsibility for the
distribution of funds that were supposed
to go to Kazakhstan she made it clear no
uranium for Giustra you are not going to
get your support from the federal
government after Giustra got those
uranium deposits he spent
thirty million dollars to the Clinton
Foundation what is the timeless fourth
yes so that's two thousand five is when
that deal happens within two months he
spent he sends the first thirty million
dollars to the Clinton Foundation two
thousand seven they do what's called a
reverse merger they take those kazakh
assets they put him in a company called
uranium one uranium one acquires uranium
assets in the United States in 2010 the
Russian government says we want to buy
uranium one that triggers the federal
approval of the United States as the US
federal government and the State
Department is considering that deal the
chairman of uranium one Ian Telfer
sends two point three five million
dollars to the Clinton Foundation
through a private foundation it was
never disclosed it was only discovered
by going through Canadian tax records
Bill Clinton gives a half a million
dollar speech the month is that approval
is going through to a a company in in
Russia that is involved financially with
uranium one the ties and the deals go on
and on and let me just add Sean by the
way it's about to get a lot more
interesting because we know some details
about this lobbyist to this this source
that's come forward his name is William
Campbell he lives in Florida he was with
Cassidy and associates which is one of
the big lobbying firms in in DC where he
lobbied on Russian interests from 2007
to 2008 he then started his own firm was
paid fifty thousand dollars a month by
the Russians for lobbying and this is
what his contract was for quote to
improve the media and political
environment in the u.s. in respect to
the surprise of the Russian uranium
products in quote to set up meetings in
with US administration officials members
of Congress and other key opinion elite
in 10x and Russian government officials
so this is a very inside vendor that's
coming forward as this whistleblower
Russia we we had Putin bad actors in the
United States Muller was the FBI
director Eric Holder was one of the nine
that signed off on the deal Sophia's
deal the committee then you got bribery
extortion kickbacks money laundering and
racketeer
mother had to know because they had an
FBI informant he had his own personal
experience ended up for years being an
informant then he got tapes and then
we've got documents and we got emails
and a first-hand account and that Putin
was using all of breaking all of these
laws to get a foothold in the Iranian
market and they knew in 2009 you're
right Sean in fact the purchase of
uranium 1 was announced by Vladimir
Putin himself it was reported in the
Moscow Times which is an
english-language publication in Moscow
he personally released the funds to
purchase uranium 1 in the United States
and look the argument that the Clinton
defenders use is well there were all
these government agencies that were
involved in this process she didn't do
it by herself from the standpoint of
bribery that is irrelevant if you're a
congressman sitting on a committee and a
committee yoke's votes unanimously for
something but you got paid to vote for
that it doesn't matter what your
colleagues did you committed bribery and
that's why this needs to be investigated
all right Peter we're gonna stay on this
and by the way the FBI informant I was
talking about his name was revealed
today we have John Solomon Sarah Carter
coming